moi j'ai travaillé une vingtaine
d'années dans les ministères de la
défense français sur différentes
domaines qui à quel poste tout sauf de
l'administration c'est à dire affaires
stratégiques exportations d'armements
renseignement d'une manière générale
réflexion sur l'organisation du
ministère poste que j'ai quitté au début
des années 2000 pour diriger une société
d'intelligence économique pendant
environ huit ans maintenant ça va je
suis retraité heureux parce que je peux
faire ce que j'ai envie de faire c'est à
dire en fait écrire je suis libéré de la
parole bonjour bien connaissent à
bonjour nous vous interview aujourd'hui
pour une chaîne youtube qui s'appelle
thinker view on aurait voulu discuter un
petit peu de l'arabie saoudite qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire à l'heure
actuelle au vu de l'actualité les câbles
wikileaks
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
le l'arabie saoudite est un pays
absolument magnifique c'est une espèce
de disneyland de l'islam c'est à dire
que tout est faux
c'est à dire vous avez des gens qui
croient qu'ils pratiquent une religion
et qui la pratiquent pas
les mises arrive à tout interdire c'est
à dire y'a pas de ya pas de cinéma n'y a
pas de bibliothèque il n'y a pas de
théâtre y a rien été puisque tout ça
évidemment détournent de la religion
mais paradoxalement quand les saoudiens
sont à l'étranger tout à coup ils
deviennent de véritables voyous ils se
payent des prostituées boivent de
l'alcool etc puis ensuite quand il
rentre au pays bas il faut qu'il donne
du sens au fond de gros dons à des
organisations humanitaires qui vont en
général finance et des choix là donc
c'est un pays assez étonnant dans sa
dans sa structure sociale
après
wikileaks de câbles wikileaks ben c'est
à dire que les câbles de wikileaks n'ont
fait que révéler c'est une chose qu'on
croque on subodorait enfin dont on
penser qu'effectivement elle était elle
était assez systématique mais on en
avait pas de preuves bien évidente c'est
à dire que l'arabie saoudite est un pays
qui est un qui est un pays magique
puisque finalement le niveau de vie par
tête doit être probablement le plus
élevé de la planète mais essentiellement
parce que c'est un énorme producteur de
pétrole et donc que qui est une
diplomatie du carnet de chèques pour
acheter des élites dans un certain
nombre de pays n'est pas en soi très
étonnant cela dit on peut effectivement
faire du carnet de chèques direct où on
peut faire des intérêts communs si vous
les gens font mouche avec la famille ben
laden par exemple donc encore une fois
c'est wikileaks a révélé des choses
qu'on subodorait mais en apportant des
preuves précise toutefois qu'au liban et
c est ce que vous pouvez développer un
petit peu la position avec ben laden la
famille ben laden la famille bush non la
famille ben laden n'est pas en soi un
sujet d'intérêt parce que d'abord c'est
une énorme famille banquiers qu'il y ait
deux dans des gens qu'ils soient proches
de mohamed le terrorisme outre il ya des
gens qui soient qui s'appelle aussi
mohamed ben laden et qui rien à voir
avec lui c'est une réalité il ya un
avocat d'ailleurs francophones qui
portent exactement le même nom et qui en
fait est un avocat d'affaires
parfaitement respectable donc la famille
ben laden c'est pas une totalité c'est
une entité hétérogènes celui qui nous
intéresse évidemment c'est celui qui
évidemment été emporté à notre affection
il ya quelques années donc
c'est intéressant c'est pas le fait que
la famille ben laden c'est surtout le
fait que quand on a eu les attentats du
11 septembre on sait bien que
le gouvernement américain a autorisé ce
qu'ils vivaient deux familles ben laden
aux états unis à s'en aller discrètement
mais le tour de passe passe le plus
prodigieux de l'arabie saoudite c'est
quand même le fait que quand l'on s'y
attarde plus joueuse je vous coupe ce
tour de passe-passe l'exfiltration de la
famille ben laden quand l'espace aérien
américain a été fermé c'est ça ouais
c'est ça exactement donc dans le tour de
passe passe le plus étonnant et qui
finalement est magnifique dans son dans
sa réalisation c'est le fait iront
saoudiens sur 19 terroristes dans les
attentats du 11 septembre et que deux
mois plus tard george bush est dense que
les pays de l'axé du mal c'est l'irak
l'iran et la corée du nord et il évite
soigneusement l'arabie saoudite donc ça
c'est un tour de passe-passe stratégique
auquel je regrette que les européens se
soient prêtés en silence puisque quand
même c'était un c'était une évidence que
ce pays était déjà vérolé par le
terrorisme à cause de sa pratique de
l'islam et que arrivé à l'éviter pour ne
pas toucher à des intérêts économiques
commerciaux pétroliers et c était quand
même une escroquerie intellectuelle et
stratégiques encore une fois auquel les
gouvernants de l'époque enfin on était
dans les mois du 11 septembre c'était
difficile de critiquer le gouvernement
américain le résultat on l'a vu c'est
qu'il ya eu l'invasion de l'irak et dont
on n'est toujours pas dans les
conséquences continuent encore
aujourd'hui alors vous parliez de
la diplomatie du carnet de chèques
est-ce qu'on voit un petit peu la
diplomatie religieuse du car des
tchèques marché nous dans le monde
entier qu'est-ce qui se passe oui
l'autre aspect qui me paraît très
intéressant c'est la diplomatie
religieuse de l'arabie saoudite parce
que la diplomatie du carnet de chèques à
la limite c'est de la diplomatie
classique c'est ce que faisait vos bouts
tout aussi pour rester au pouvoir dire
qu'ils paient à droite et à gauche pour
pouvoir être sûr que les élections ne
perturbe pas soit sa dictature non ce
qui est le plus intéressant c'est que à
partir de 73 l'arabie saoudite à cause
de la du boom pétrolier des prix du
pétrole va toucher en trois jours ce
qu'elle touche en un an et se trouve
donc à la tête d'une masse financières
gigantesques et pour bien comprendre le
régime saoudien il faut savoir que c'est
pas un régime politique ou religieux
c'est à dire que c'est l'alliance des
wahhabites enfin les dissidents
d'abdelwahab et de la famille ses hôtes
qui vont faire ce régime saoudien fois
et donc à la tête de cette fortune
immense qu'il faut qu'ils explosent à
partir de 73 se développent une
diplomatie religieuse qui dans le cadre
de l'islam va essentiellement consisté à
développer la pratique saoudienne de
l'islam c'est-à-dire 6,7 pardon plus
rigoristes oui la plus rigolote c'est à
dire celle qui coupe les mains des
voleurs qui décapite qui opprime les
femmes et qui interdisent autres
religions donc général et vous ces
critères-là faut les retenir parce qu'on
les retrouve ailleurs et donc et par
hasard et par extraordinaire aussi quand
les médicis d'abdelwahab arrivent et
prennent la mecque en même temps l'insee
où ils détruisent le cimetière dans
lequel sont enterrés les compagnons du
prophète c'est pour dire que c'est des
rigoristes au sens où il n'y a que
l'instauration de dieu même les
compagnons du prophète leurs tombes ne
sont même pas sont considérés comme
impies parce que ça pourrait développer
un culte des saints donc dans ce grand
humanisme qui est la pratique saoudienne
delà de l'islam donc on va essayer de va
diffuser elle va être diffusée un peu
partout sur la planète avec des moyens
financiers gigantesques c'est à dire que
ont créé des madrassas donc des écoles
coraniques en distribue des bourses en
distribue des bouquins on en distribue
des bourses pour des étudiants qui
veulent venir en arabie saoudite
g de courant on donne évidemment très
largement la version la traduction et
saoudienne du coran ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait la même que d'autres
traductions et donc autour de ces foyers
dans des pays cette stratégie est
planétaire c'est ça qui est très
étonnant c'est à dire que ça viens
évidemment ici on a eu pas mal d'imams
saoudien qui nous ont été fournis en
même temps que la construction de
mosquées et donc quand même par contre
ce qu'on n'a pas eu leurs deux raisons
de regarder ses 6 passes et ailleurs en
afrique subsaharienne où on a vu par
exemple au mali qui avaient des
salafistes et l'on s'était on a été
surpris qu'il en est on en a vus en rca
on envoie au niger au nigeria etc c est
donc cette stratégie était planétaire
mais on n'a pas surveillé parce que
notre réseau diplomatique n'a pas
vocation à surveiller les évolutions des
cultes du musulman dans les pays où il
est installé que faisait la dgse mais la
dgse ne s'occupait pas de ça c'est à
dire que on était à partir de 79 la
donne stratégique est complètement
transformé et surtout l'arabie saoudite
devient un allié essentiel d'un pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que des bus
on disait il ya la révolution iranienne
un huissier iranienne c'est une
révolution démocratique ça personne ne
doute si vous voulez ensuite on pense
qu'on veut du régime mais en tout cas
les gens étaient dans la rue et les
saoudiens sont tétanisés à l'idée qu'il
puisse y avoir un régime politique
chiite non arabe qui s'installent à leur
porte et qui puisse prétendre prendre le
leadership sur la communauté musulmane
donc ça ce choc terrible mais ils ont
une opportunité formidable qui est fait
que fin 79 même année les soviétiques
envahissent l'afghanistan est donc à ce
moment là ils vont prendre la tête du
djihad c'est à ce moment là que ressort
le terme pour aller combattre les
mécréants s'alliant les soviétiques qui
pour eux sont dans la même catégorie des
occidentaux rassemblement effectivement
états qui sont les banques qui sont les
méchants mais tous sont des mécréants et
donc il va y avoir le soutien aux avoués
en résistant l'union soviétique et une
grande participation de beaucoup de
saoudiens d'ailleurs à cette guerre on
pense que le vrai 70% des combattants
étrangers à l'époque sont deviennent de
l'arabie saoudite alors se passe à ce
moment là un processus qu'elle a aussi
qu'on n'a pas vu arriver c'est que parmi
les conditions mises par le prince turki
le chef des services de renseignement
par lequel transitent et l'aide pour les
pakistanais pour les afghans il va
opposer au régime du mâle calaisien qui
est un régime islamiste mais
amateur s'ils voulaient par rapport aux
saoudiens il va lui imposer l'ouverture
de madrassas donc d'écoles coraniques
version voit vite et puis avec tout ce
qui va avec les bourses et les bouquins
les bibliothèques les machins de teint
et le produit final on va voir sortir
c'est les talibans sita talibans
étymologiquement c'est les étudiants en
religion c'est à dire ces gens qui vont
tout à coup raser tout ce qu'ils
trouvent sur leur passage qui vont déjà
mettre en oeuvre ce qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui à des ch ou ce qui est
régulièrement pratiqué en arabie
saoudite c'est à dire la lapidation des
femmes
décapitations et c'est donc pour les
homosexuels ils ont fait preuve
d'inventivité puisque estimé que les
homosexuels il fallait écraser il
fallait comme buldozer écrase un mur sur
dont il était quand même assez novateur
les talibans dans la dans la répression
donc le simultanément autre épisode
aussi en algérie vous avez dix années de
guerre civile où vous avez des
salafistes léger les groupes islamiques
armés gia puis ensuite le gspc le groupe
salafiste pour la prédication et le
combat qui vont massacrer d'autres
musulmans en algérie ça fait plutôt
quand même plus de cent mille 100 à 150
mille morts c'est pas très bien mais
encore une fois tout ça ce sont des
conséquences indirectes de ce jihad qui
au départ étaient tournés contre les
mécréants et puis qui progressivement va
se tourner contre les régimes arabes
mécréants c'est à dire les régimes de
mauvais musulmans
mauvais musulmans parce que peut-être à
la botte des pays occidentaux ou
instrumentalisés par les pays
occidentaux ou jugés comme
instrumentalisé par les pays occidentaux
c'est un mélange de plusieurs choses
c'est à dire que les salafistes
considère d'abord que le principe
constitutionnel qui soit dictatorial au
qui soit démocratique de toute façon
prétendre et supris comment dire su
rendre supérieur la loi des hommes à la
par rapport à la loi de dieu donc ya pas
besoin de constitution dans un régime
salafistes du moment qu'on applique la
charia qu'on a vu qu'on suit le coran on
va chercher toutes les questions dans le
coran à ce moment là on se il ya même
pas besoin de savoir si le régime même
écran ou pas puisque le régime doit pas
exister et donc ils soient alliés des
occidentaux qu'ils le soient pas c'est à
dire ils vont se battre contre le père
assad par exemple avec une insurrection
les frères musulmans particulier mais
qui va être réprimée dans le sang par le
père assad dans la ville de hama mais
ils vont se battre de la même façon
contre le régime algérien qui se prétend
le successeur de la guerre
d'indépendance était donc encore une
fois c'est pas la base alliance
occidentale ou pas c'est la contestation
de leur légitimité comme gouvernants et
donc encore une fois tout doit être
dicté par le coran par exemple l'épisode
rigolo quand il ya eu la sphère clinton
monica levinsky par exemple un qu'il
s'était fait faire une fellation par une
stagiaire il ya eu un débat sur al
jazeera qui est une radio qatari est une
télé qatarie sur le thème est ce que la
fellation est halal ou pas avec des les
docteurs en théologie à qui venait
donner leur avis notamment par la
période du ramadan posez une question
importante puisque vous voyez bien le
problème technique que ça pose est donc
il ya eu c'est ce genre de choses c'est
à dire l'idée qu'on a dans une lecture
littérale du coran réponse à tout même
peut-être sur internet et on va ils vont
trouver demain des réponses aussi encore
une fois c'est cette pratique là c'est à
dire la plus obscurantistes et cette
diplomatie religieuse en 35 ans c'est à
peu près 15 cents mosquées qui sont
ouvertes avec des fonds saoudiens 1 100
mosquée ça commence à faire pas mal tout
ce qui est en france non sur l'ensemble
de l'action de la planète parce que
cette action est quand même un peu
partout sur le sur la planète encore une
fois beaucoup en afrique en asie
beaucoup aussi pas mal an pas mal en
russie à partir de 91 il ya aujourd'hui
des islamistes au tatarstan il a
évidemment caucase etc c'est donc c'est
cette vision planétaire on a eu beaucoup
de mal à combat surveiller puisque
finalement chacun de ces postes ne vais
pas se demander ce que fait l'arabie
saoudite il aurait fallu d'impulsion
politique en disant mais qu'est ce que
fait l'arabie saoudite dans ses
différents endroits et là on entend dans
un débat qui est beaucoup plus générale
c'est à dire comment les occidentaux se
sont ils comportés vis-à-vis du régime
alors par exemple richard baer le patron
de l'un des patrons de du renseignement
américain raconté que pendant longtemps
il était interdit de faire du
renseignement sur l'arabie saoudite
interdit
sur l'arabie saoudite mais en france on
peut
à oui biensur mais encore une fois le
lever tôt était venu pour des raisons
politiques pas pour des raisons
stratégiques c'est-à-dire qu'ils avaient
peur qu'un incident diplomatique un type
se fasse prendre et pas à partir de ce
moment là toutes sanctions commerciales
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer mais je veux
dire la lâcheté stratégique que ça
représente est assez gigantesque je sais
pas ce qu'il en était pour les français
sont enfin en tout cas pour les
américains on a eu confirmation que
c'était interdit vous parlez de
l'acheter
à l'heure actuelle est ce que vous
pensez que la position du gouvernement
français vis-à-vis de l'arabie saoudite
est une position de lâches c'est à dire
que le on se trouve dans cette situation
étonnante où on est en train de faire la
guerre à d'âge pour des raisons
qui sont assez évidentes à on a décapité
les types en coupe les mains des voleurs
on opprime les femmes on interdit aux
autres religions donc si vous voyez vous
manque une case il faut la remplir si
parce que vous en faites vous parlez de
l'arabie saoudite d'où partent des
neiges l'arabie saoudite c'est pareil
voix et donc on en arrive à se battre
entre dèche d'une manière qui d'ailleurs
dans sa motivation est passé scandaleuse
quand vous avez des sites de jeunes
islamistes en france et qui vous disent
nous semblera gaza en fait rien quatre
occidentaux égorgé en envoie l'armée on
peut comprendre qu'ils soient
scandalisés par une diplomatie de double
standard comme ça bref on se retrouve à
se battre à côté des américains contre
des shs régime pour lequel on peut ne
pas en avoir aucune sympathie 1 mais
pour défendre celui qui a donné
naissance c'est à dire l'arabie saoudite
ça fait un peu comme dans le roman de
mary shelley c'est à dire que quand le
docteur frankenstein voudrais bien qu'on
le débarrasse de son monde de son
monstre mais dans le roman il disparaît
en même temps que lui tandis que nous on
voudrait que le monstre fait
disparaissent mais pas le géniteur donc
c'est à côté a un côté un peu cocasse un
exemple si vous voulez quand on regarde
la structure des forces qui bombarde
daraîche aujourd'hui les saoudiens ont
deux fois moins d'avions que les
français et par contre ils ont deux fois
plus que pour se battre au yémen contre
les chiites
ils ont autant d'avions que les danois
et les hollandais acide auditionnés bon
on a quand même l'impression que ça
ressemble à une croisade quand on est du
côté des sunnites et donc on a fait la
bêtise il fallait au vocation terroriste
réaction est évidemment maintenant c'est
dans un système où qu'est ce que vous
pensez des déclarations de manuel valls
concernant cette guerre de civilisation
roche je pense est une équipe
déclarations de les mois c'est à dire
qu'il a voulu marquer par un propos à
mon avis exagéré en tout cas qu'il
traduit pas la réalité qu' il y avait
quelque chose qui interpellé si vous
voulez là nos sociétés moi je rappelle
sans bien sûr si on fait c'est perçu
comme une croisade
abbas est perçu par eux comme une
croisade toute façon donc c'est ça qui
est important parce que le difficulté du
sujet c'est que quand des occidentaux
disent croisade ça une connotation
positive alors que pour les musulmans
c'est une connotation très négative
puisque c'est là que l'action intérieur
lice par nature et quand nous on parle
de djihad par nature c'est une
intervention agressive alors que pour
les musulmans ça peut être une espèce de
discipline personnelle pour s'améliorer
et donc les termes ont un double sens et
ce qui fait que même si on parle pas de
croisade ses prix comme une croisade par
eux mêmes si je ne parle pas de dire
qu'on va le prendre pour le diable même
prendre ça ne l'est pas donc le la
déclaration de manuel valls est c'est
fait dans l'émoi évidemment d'une
décapitation mais si on y réfléchit bien
il ya eu quand même une cinquantaine de
morts dans une mosquée chiite au koweït
il ya eu 37 morts en tunisie sur une
plage et il ya eu un homme décapité en
france
l'ordre des ennemis pour des shows c'est
pas celui de la france c'est les
chiffres d'abord parce que ce sont les
musulmans dissidents etc ce sont les
catégories des mauvais musulmans c'est
le troisième attentat sur une mosquée
chiite dans la région de en arabie
saoudite le troisième vous pouvez
imaginer une minute qu'on mette une
bombe dans une mosquée ici vous voyez le
scandale que ça provoque ray ça ne
choque même pas la communauté musulmane
ici c'est à dire qu'il ya une espèce
d'empathie si vous voulez vis-à-vis de
ce qui se passe là bas comme si les
chiites étaient des gens méprisable
qu'il faille est massacrée
deuxième caractéristique le tourisme en
tunisie c'est à dire contre le régime
démocratique arabe on revient dans la
logique pour les voleurs et troisième
épisodes seulement celui de ce type en
isère
qui va tenter de faire exploser un site
seveso mais avec beaucoup de bricolage
donc le le coût du l'acteur solitaire si
vous voulez c'est à la fois le risque
qu'il est très difficile de presse
contre lesquelles il est très difficile
de se prémunir puisque ça peut être
n'importe où n'importe pas mais l'
avantage de cet inconvénient c'est que
le type ne peut pas monter un système
trop compliqué c'est à dire qu'il ne
peut pas imaginer de faire un attentat
organisé par ce que tous les systèmes de
surveillance des montants un réseau
dense il ya la fragilité de la vente âge
si vous avez parlé d'un agenda d'un
calendrier de prise de position par
bardèche
israël dans le calendrier ça se trouve
entre les pays arabes la france dans la
stratégie de déranger c'est pas israël
c'est les juifs c'est les juifs c'est le
cndd terme générique
c'est à dire pour eux c'est la théorie
du complot les juifs sont partout
alors par exemple qui est très cocasse
si vous voulez c'est que quand vous
regardez un des principaux ressorts de
la mobilisation de la conversion que
salafistes arrive à exercer sur internet
c'est la thématique et la méthodologie
des sectes de l'apocalypse c'est à dire
la fin du monde est pour bientôt et donc
si vous devenez un bon croyant pendant
le court laps de temps qui vous reste à
vivre ce moment là vous avez des chances
d'échapper à l'enfer et ses
thématiques qu'on avait chez les témoins
de jéhovah qu'on avait chez jim johnson
avait chez d'autres mais eux c'est
l'annoncé de l'apocalypse appuyé sur la
réalité historique puisque la guerre en
syrie c'était selon eux ce qu'avait
annoncé le prophète donc on se retrouve
dans un système où là comment dire dans
cette pureté exigé pour atteindre
l'apocalypse dans les meilleures
conditions il ya l'élimination de tous
ceux qui vont vous entravé c'est à dire
c'est une théorie générale du complot
dans lequel il ya les mauvais musulmans
qui peuvent commencer par la famille
ensuite il ya effectivement tous ceux
qui par nature sont comment dire des
traîtres à l'islam il faut penser que
par exemple
khaled kelkal vous savez qui était le
type qui était bien été but et dans la
région lyonnaise il était à l'origine
des attentats de saint michel 2 de
luxembourg où 84 96 94 93 cents il avait
été interviewé par le sociologue
allemand un an avant quand il est un
jeune type delà des minguettes et il
disait le schisme a été inventé par les
juifs pour diviser l'islam c'est-à-dire
qu'il arrivait à rendre les juifs même
responsable du chiisme est donc cette
accusation génériques contre les juifs
c'est tous les juifs est par nature
mauvais d'où l'attitude de mera avec les
enfants de l'école d'art à tora
quel est donc ce n'est pas israël
puisque israël c'est trop difficile pour
eux c'est inaccessible donc il faut
commander de la lecture de la stratégie
est ce que vous pensez que des shows
pratique la stratégie de l'anaconda
c'est à dire la stratégie de
l'encerclement d'israël pour ensuite
serré c'est à nous non je crois pas
d'abord parce que il est pas qu au
contact d'israël au contraire même il
est au contact de dieu de l'armée de
bagdad de l'armée de assad il est au
contraire en comment dire enfermés dans
une guerre encore une foi religieuse
interne à l'islam les massacres
aujourd'hui sont des massacres intra
musulmans quand on regarde les
statistiques du terrorisme par exemple
aujourd'hui par exemple les bases
américaines le terrorisme aujourd'hui tu
dix fois plus de musulmans que non
musulmans ça veut dire que encore une
fois là où on pense qu'il ya un acte
terroriste dont la logique politique et
de s'opposer à nous non
la logique politique de ce terrorisme
menace est d'exterminer les mauvais
musulmans d'abord et donc les soufis
donc les cheats donc les mauvais
musulmans donc les mâles équipe et de
détruire tous les signes de ces
pratiques ignobles quand les salafistes
arrive au mali il commence par détruire
les bibliothèques bibliothèque malikite
comme l'avaient fait les talibans en
d'autres temps comme l'a fait le gspc en
algérie donc à une espèce de matrice
idéologique si vous l'étiez de même
nature que celle de l'arabie saoudite
c'est celle qu'elle a diffusé un peu
dans tous ces essais madrasa et encore
une fois l'ordre des ennemis n'est pas
celui qu'on imagine donc la question
politique c'est faut-il intervenir dans
une guerre de religion
voyez ma question c'est que quand on
arrive dans une guerre de religion etc a
fortiori on n'appartient pas à cette
religion est ce qu on est on est un
croisé
on veut revenir sur l'arabie saoudite à
notre époque
vos préconisations si vous aviez les
commandes
d'abord il ya une préconisation
essentiel c'est qu'on peut pas se battre
à la place des autres c'est à dire on
est parti comme ça au moment des
décapitations mais sans aucune
conditionnalité politique c'est à dire
on va reprocher à des ce qui se pratique
régulièrement en arabie saoudite et ne
pas oublier que l'arabie saoudite vient
de l'ancien un appel à propositions
appel à candidature parce qu'ils
manquent de bourgogne ayant ils veulent
recruter huit bureaux donc
c'est ce pays là qu'on va essayer de
défendre autre exemple si vous voulez
d'actualité il ya un jeune type qui
s'est permis sur son blog de dire que la
police religieuse avait des pouvoirs
excessifs en arabie saoudite il a été
condamné à dix ans de prison et 1000
coups de fouet mille coups de fouet il
s'appellera yes badaoui je n'ai pas vu
de pétitions de bhl ou de quelque chose
soit sur le sujet un beau remis peu
importe le mille coups de fouet le type
il fera jamais ses dix ans de prison il
sera mort avant et je n'ai jamais
entendu une quelconque critique contre
le système saoudien d'un quelconque
homme politique français on va donner
des leçons à la planète entière on va
expliquer que poutine d'un horrible
dictateur et que évidemment si jean ping
le chinois est lui aussi fait des camps
de concentration mais jamais on a levé
le moindre sourcils pour dire aux
saoudiens c'est pas bien parce qu'on
entend sonner dans une guerre et qu'on
défend ce régime là on peut quand même
posé quelques conditionnalité politique
est-ce que vous pensez que on ne
critique pas l'arabie saoudite parce que
l'arabie saoudite est la tête de pont
américaine dans la région non je crois
pas je crois que via iad il ya des
logiques françaises et américaines qui
sont un peu différents des avis de
l'arabie saoudite la logique américaine
effectivement est aujourd'hui quand même
de se libérer le plus possible de la
dépendance énergétique saoudienne et
s'ils réussissent avec le gaz de schiste
avec le pétrole de schiste
les français sont dans une dépendance
commerciale très importante à l'égard de
l'arabie saoudite et ont fait taire
toutes les critiques avec la perspective
de 10 milliards de une signature de
contrat depuis je travaille sur l'arabie
saoudite est toujours 10 milliards en
instance donc
le chiffre ne m'intéresse pas tellement
ça se réalise rarement les 10 milliards
d'un coup mais en fait je fais remarquer
que dans les contres en négociations on
vante deux centrales nucléaires
européennes à l'arabie saoudite et que
visiblement en iran dès qu'ils
commencent à développer du nucléaire
même de technologies assez classique on
trouve ça très inquiétant dans un pays
qui n'a aucun tissu industriel comme
l'arabie saoudite qui n'a aucun n
comment dire de sociologie de la jenny
ring de ce genre de sujet je comprends
pas la logique qui va entretenir ce
central et surtout qui va les surveiller
on leur a vendu en laboratoire p4 un
laboratoire p4 si les laboratoires
extrêmement sécurisé dans lesquels en
particulier on travaille contre les
armes chimiques et bactériologiques
je vais de voudrais rencontrer le
premier ingénieur saoudien qui va
diriger ce laboratoire p4
donc je sais pas je comprends pas la
logique française on est engagé dans un
système d'alliances où l'on concède à
peu près tout ce que demandent les
saoudiens même si on sait que
sociologiquement technologiquement
professionnellement ils n'ont pas le
début du cadre du premier personnel pour
garder sur le prix donc je ne sais pas
je vous pose trois petits trop petite
question pour terminer la première
l'asile à un songe qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ah ben moi je trouve que c'est
inadmissible la façon dont on l'a traité
enfin et a fortiori pour snowdon cet
annuaire penser qu'on a interdit un
président d'un état indépendant de
survoler le territoire français parce
qu'on supposait qu'il était peut-être
dans son avion je veux dire qu'on a
rarement été aussi hypocrite et aussi
veulent que dans cette décision là et
pour assange c'est une ssii estime le
suit au cap de l'année sa
suite au cap delà de la nsa sur les
écoutes peut oui ou non et puis pour
assange si vous voulez il nous rend
service en nous montrant que nous sommes
écoutés le président est écouté il avait
montré à merkel pour ce qui concerne
l'allemagne et c'est qu'on a perdu des
marchés à cause de ces de ces écoutes
oui mais ça on le savait depuis
longtemps simplement il en a apporté la
preuve a dit non c'est une voie
extérieure quand vous perdez un marché
que vous dites évidemment les américains
ont fait si on fait ça on vous croit ou
on vous croit pas la personnalité tiers
c'est lui qui apporte la preuve que et
donc ça avait cet avantage là mais
encore une fois on est dans une
situation où le type au moins on devrait
lui accorder l'asile politique c'est à
dire il est enfermé aujourd'hui dans
l'ambassade d'équateur en salle on peut
s'en sortir ça fait deux ans deux ans et
demi qu'il est là bas et encore une fois
même s'il doit être jugé en suède il est
évident que l'europe doit voter une
résolution pour qu'il ne soit pas
extradé aux états unis qui soit accusé
de quelque chose par les suédois je fais
confiance à la justice suédoise mais
penser qu'ils puissent ensuite être
extradé aux états unis pour marquer des
pas noir dont il sera pas buter dans une
rue et c'est déjà ça donc il est blanc
dont il sera jugé il sera condamné à la
prison à perpétuité parce que vous savez
que l' avantage du système américain
c'est on peut être condamné à 375 ans de
prison donc même avec réduction de peine
en général on n'en sort pas donc ça
c'est ce qui reste du passé s'est passé
c'est cela qui ont été condamnés le
jeune soldat qui avait approvisionner
snowdon si vous voulez sur bradley
manning est maintenant sur le fond
l'europe fait preuve d'une indignité
admissibles sur la sphère de assange
deuxième petite question la parole
diplomatiques européennes et la parole
diplomatique française a tiré pas de
paroles diplomatique européen des biens
porte pas son nom parce que regarder il
ya eu deux scénarios dans laquelle dans
lesquels l'europe s'est totalement
divisé la première c'est l'invasion
américaine en irak une partie de
l'europe ival parti va pas à l'honneur
de la france la position de chirac
disant non on n'ira pas c'est une gare
inadmissible et c'est super bon mais
vous avez quand même l'espagne l'italie
l'angleterre qui vont la suite vous la
connaissez les attentes à madrid et à
temps en angleterre donc on devrait
réfléchir sur le passé c'est à dire
qu'encore une fois quand un pays
s'engage dans une guerre à l'extérieur
il peut y avoir dans sa propre
communauté musulmane des gens qui sont
en désaccord et qui donc légitiment leur
violence terroriste sur place par le
fait que ont tué des musulmans là bas
exemple qui n'a servi à rien puisque de
toute façon nous on s'est engagé dans la
deuxième version de la guerre en irak
c'est à dire celle contre dèche dans
laquelle cette fois les espagnoles et
italiennes sont pas allés vous avez
remarqué mais pareil en est dans un
système où l'europe s'est divisée et
dont il n'y a pas de paroles européenne
les scandinaves considère pas que
sécurité se joue en irak jeudi mire tout
chine et vladimir poutine m'a écouté
c'est un amateur poutine à côté du roi
d'arabie saoudite je veux dire c'est
vrai on a raison de lui donner des
leçons mais sur le fond si on devait
faire un ordre d'abord on commencerait
par foot george bush devant la cour
pénale internationale
ensuite dans descendants si vous voulez
dans l'ordre hiérarchique effectivement
on pourrait éventuellement prendre le
roi d'arabie saoudite woods autres donc
on est dans ce système et horner par
exemple j'ai vu l'a récemment sur une
dépêche qu'il ya un des princes
saoudiens qui va dédier sa fortune à
faire des actions humanitaires améliorer
la compréhension entre les peuples etc
je veux dire vous allez discuter
dialogue des cultures et les saoudiens
ou je crois pas même que le mot se
traduisent en arabe saoudien c'est à
dire vous allez parler tolérance avec
ces gens là c'est pas possible donc les
mecs ont de l'argent et ils sont prêts à
raconter n'importe quoi en disant on va
financer donc on est dans un système
c'est formidable c'est un théâtre
d'ombrés il faut qu'ils nous dise un
truc on fait semblant d'y croire on leur
répond quelque chose au pdi font
semblant de croire mais c'est évident
qu'il ya un problème stratégique majeur
qui est celui de l'évolution de l'arabie
saoudite son comportement diplomatique
sa réforme l'ouverture de ces de ces
pratiques
cultuelle à l'égard des autres musulmans
et l'arrêt de l'espèce de savez les
américains une ong américaine qui a
regardé par exemple les manuels
d'enseignement saoudiens et notamment
dans des écoles la mairie qui sont aux
etats unis puisque il en a ouvert
certains et vous trouver des phrases du
genre un bon musulman ne doit avoir
aucune relation avec un mécréant non
seulement il ne doit pas avoir de
relations amicales mais en plus il doit
le détester je vous la fais bref quoi
les anglais ont eu le même constat ils
ont constaté dans des écoles blair qui
est un espèce de faux culs assez
étonnant avait autorisé chacune des
communautés à ouvrir ses propres écoles
en dix ans une diversité culturelle il
ya eu des rapports d'inspection de
l'équivalent de notre inspection de
l'éducation nationale qui se sont faites
sur ces écoles là où ils ont constaté
qu'avaient séparation des hommes et des
garçons et des filles que les
non-musulmans été mis de côté et quand
cris présenté comme voyage scolaire le
pèlerinage à la mecque et c'est bon et
on jeudi mais attendez on est parti dans
quelle direction là c'est à dire on peut
pas faire croire que ces types sont
respectables savez vous dit allen
définissez la la liberté de parole ou
l'ami liberté de la liberté ii dans le
droit constitutionnel des démocraties en
dix ans la liberté de parole c'est pas
donné le même temps de parole à hitler à
une victime de la shoah or nous on est
en train de faire comme si ce pays parce
qu'il a de l'argent et est respectable
il ne la gestion voient la dernière
question un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
écoutez moi j'ai été très comment dire
très agréablement surpris parce que les
gens que j'ai rencontrés dans la
communauté française musulmane parce que
d'abord cette communauté et en
intégration entièrement à ce qu'on
raconte le ya énormément de classe moyen
de musulmanes qui sont ingénieurs
techniciens de ses 30 septembre et en
particulier il ya beaucoup de jeunes à
qui il faut faire de la place encore une
fois parce qu'il faut leur raconter les
success stories de cette communauté faux
pas faut pas raconter si vous voulez que
les sur les routes la communauté sur les
mecs sont partis à neige mais vous avez
des types comme yazid sabeg comme le
président du racing club de toulon je
veux dire ils ont pas ils seront pas
tentés de partir pour des ch donc il ya
encore une fois rapport avec cette
communauté que je trouve aujourd'hui
important puisque les attentats
terroristes sont modifiées l'ambiance et
puis encore une fois c'est un problème
interne aux élites musulmanes
aujourd'hui c'est une guerre de religion
il faut que les types enseigne la
tolérance parce que s'il enseigne pas
ils sont nos veines sont massacrés entre
eux et donc c'est pas la responsabilité
des américains comme je l'entends
souvent c'est pas la responsabilité des
français l'examen critique de cette
évolution de l'islam c'est aux élites
musulmanes ou aux français de culture
musulmane de la faire il ya des
universitaires français qu'ils le font
ces types sont formidables parce que il
enseigne en enseignement critique de
l'islam toutes les religions
monothéistes ont été un tollé rente
premier principe il ya que mon dieu quel
bon c'est la légitimation du massacre
des autres donc on va pas nous raconter
que cela ils sont plus l'amour et la
paix que les autres noms comme toutes
les religions simplement ils ont un
décalage de quelques siècles par rapport
à nos propres guerres de religion c'est
à dire qu'ils les font au 21ème siècle
alors que nous on les a faits au 17e
mais les conclusions sont les mêmes en
général après un siècle au mascaret
convergence pierre connais ça merci
merci
[Musique]
le